joe biden openly states he will not give
his position on court packing until
after the election
the commission on presidential debate
skews the process against trump and
michigan governor gretchen whitmer
blames trump for a terror plot against
her i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten in a
vpn yet visit expressvpn.com
ben okay so yeah i've been telling you a
lot over the last week and a half about
the poll numbers because and i get a lot
of letters from people why are you
talking about the polls so much don't
you know the polls are just wrong well
i mean on the national level the polls
were not all that wrong in 2016.
on the state level they were wrong by a
couple of points they were not wrong
by 8 or ten points okay right now the
bottom line is
that president trump is trailing that
does not mean that he has no chance it
does not mean the race is over
it does mean that if i'm going to convey
the most up-to-date information you have
to take into account the polling numbers
especially because polling companies
generally have an interest
in being as accurate as possible even if
you don't like the source of
the polling but there is one poll number
today one poll number today that
suggests that trump's chances are
significantly more robust than the polls
are letting on
this is a key poll okay there's a pole
from gallup
it is american's view on whether they
are better or worse off than they were
four years ago
now given trump's poll numbers and the
fact that he is trailing you would
expect
that the vast majority of americans i
mean we're in the middle of a pandemic
an economic downturn
you would imagine the majority of
americans would say that they're worse
off than they were
four years ago if all you had done is
listen to the
the poll numbers and the media over the
past few months but
here is the actual statistic as of
september 2020
56 of americans say they are better off
than they were four years ago
56 of americans
okay that compares to 45 in december of
2012 47
in october of 2004 38
in october of 1992 and 44 in july
of 1984. that is a very very high number
if everybody who believes they were
better off than they were four years ago
voted for trump he would win
going away he would win a blowout
victory which suggests a couple of
things one
maybe the polls are actually
undersampling people who are somewhat
enthusiastic about trump but are not
actually going to talk about it
and two if trump could get his
personality out of the way
he would be winning this election in a
walk if you are the incumbent president
and nearly six in 10 americans believe
that they are better off
now than they were when you were elected
that is a great number i mean literally
ronald reagan in 1984 ran on the
campaign slogan are you better off now
than you were four years ago and the
american people said yes and they
re-elected him in mass numbers
the same thing could happen for trump if
all he did was focus in on his policies
and the fact that democrats have no
policies and when they do have policies
they are radical that they refuse to
state just how radical
and so the media have been reliant on a
narrative and we've been talking about
this for months at this point
the narrative is orange man bad bad man
orange orange bad man
right those are the variations of the
theme
okay the only theme they have is trump's
personality and trump has played into
this if trump didn't play into this
perhaps the media would be forced
to ask serious questions about joe biden
yeah maybe they wouldn't but he would
spend all of his time pressing that
forward
maybe they would be forced to ask
everyday americans about what they think
about the state of the country because
it turns out most americans are pretty
optimistic
about where they are as opposed to four
years ago that is a it's an astonishing
stat it's an unexpected stat and it's
one that should give pause to democrats
they shouldn't be too comfortable and it
should give some shot in the arm
to the trump campaign we'll get to more
of this in just one second the media
simply refusing to ask hard questions of
joe biden when they do he just ignores
them we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's be real about your cell phone bill
you're paying too much money you are
you're paying way too much money
i know you got a cellular plan with
verizon or at t and t-mobile and you
think well that's the only way i can get
coverage
wrong you are you could get the same
exact sort of coverage with the same
exact sort of cell phone towers and you
could pay half of what you're currently
paying
the average person who switches to pure
talk usa is using less than four gigs of
data a month but the big carriers are
charging you for unlimited data
it's like paying for an entire row on an
airplane but you only need one seat
that's how pure talk saves the average
person over 400
a year on their wireless service
unlimited talk text two gigs of data all
for just 20 bucks a month
if you go over on the data usage they're
not going to charge you for it folks
switching to pure talk it's the easiest
decision you will make today saving lots
of money
why wouldn't you do it grab your mobile
phone dial pounds at 250
say ben shapiro when you do you say 50
off your first month
dial pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro
pure talk it's simply smarter wireless
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro to get
started once more tell pound 250 get rid
of that big wireless carrier get
something that is
less expensive same coverage now pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro to
get started with pure talk
usa okay so that statistic that
that trump has made people more
optimistic than they were four years ago
about where they are in the country
that is that is an astonishingly
positive statistic
for an incumbent president but trump is
trailing in the polls and the media
have a stake obviously they hate trump
the coverage of trump for the last
four years since his election that
coverage
has been overwhelmingly bad i mean 90
percent of the coverage has been
negative on trump
despite all the accomplishments despite
the fact that the economy was booming
every single thing that trump has done
wrong has been magnified and every
single thing that he has done right has
been minimized
to the point where peace breaks out in
the middle east and suddenly that is now
being printed on page a18 of the new
york times
whereas if if barack obama had farted
anywhere in the general region it would
have been a1 news
anytime barack obama said a thing that
the media loved which was every single
day
a1 news whenever trump says something
that they don't like that is a1 news but
when he does something that is wonderful
that is page a18
and right now the media are so open in
their bias
it's one of the reasons why the left
cannot be allowed to win this election
because the media apparatus
have basically mobilized full score
behind the hard radical left position
while pretending to be objective at the
same time
it's insulting to the american people
it's ridiculous they've given up
any pretense that they once had of
objectivity but then they gaslight you
by claiming they continue to be
objective journalists they simply
are not and the best case in point of
this is the fact that joe biden
the democratic presidential candidate
the likely next president by the polls
and his running mate kamal harris
refused to answer a very simple but
quite important question
are you going to pack the supreme court
are you going to add seats to the
supreme court of the united states
remember
that was a policy so radical that fdr in
1937 when he tried to do this
was rebuked by members of his own party
the republicans did not control congress
at that time
democrats overwhelmingly controlled
congress and democrats in congress were
like
i think we're gonna like hit pause on
this one democrats now however are so
angry at the prospect of amy coney
barrett replacing ruth bader ginsburg on
the supreme court
because they believe the supreme court
should just be a tool of policymaking on
behalf of the left
rather than a a counter-majoritarian
institution
designed to prevent excesses that
overrun your rights which is the
original design
of the supreme court they believe the
supreme court should just be another
tool in their arsenal and they're so
angry that they want to openly make it
another tool
in their arsenal this is the game the
left play whether it's the media or
whether it's the supreme court whether
it's the executive branch
all institutions become tools in their
arsenal at the same time they claim that
those institutions have institutional
legitimacy
so they play this double game where they
wreck the institutional legitimacy but
then claim that you should respect the
institution
because the institutional legitimacy
ought to remain
and that is untenable it is so joe biden
was asked directly yesterday
again again about court packing now
remember kamal harris was asked in
debate just two nights ago
what she would do about court packing
and she refused to answer the question
and mike pence kept drilling her on it
and she kept refusing to answer the
question and then eventually
she just called him a racist so joe
biden standing far away from kamala
harrison an airplane hangar in phoenix
arizona
he was asked specifically about court
packing and his answer is so
unacceptable for any political candidate
that it should have the media up in arms
i imagine i mean you don't have to
imagine it donald trump has many
many many times been asked about
particular kind of crazy policies and
donald trump's go-to
when there is a crazy policy suggestion
that he doesn't know anything about is
to say
well we've been thinking about it we
think about all options elections have
been thought about
and the media go oh well that means that
he's totally for it right i mean we
gotta take that seriously we got to take
that stuff
super seriously now the difference is
again that is trump's go-to option
but joe biden has thought pretty
seriously about court packing kamala
harris came out in 2019 and talked
openly about the possibility of court
packing
other members of the democratic party
high echelon members of the democratic
party have openly
backed court packing in the democratic
debate many of the candidates said they
would back court packing
joe biden at the time said he would not
now he has gone completely silent on the
issue which
sort of bespeaks that he may have
changed his opinion so he was asked
directly
yesterday this is not the first time he
was asked last week three separate times
in a row
whether he would back court packing he
said people are already voting people
are
are already voting and they're down here
so yesterday he was asked
about whether he would back court
packing his answer was mystery meat
there's mr remy what could this chicken
surprise be is it chicken or is it frog
who knows
you're gonna find out afterwards i saw a
tweet yesterday i saw a tweet yesterday
characterizing biden's response here
which is do you take this woman
for better or for worse do you pledge
your chastity and fidelity
you'll find out after the wedding here
was joe biden doing this i mean it's
unbelievable
they'll know my opinion of court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline and every one of your
papers will be about that
other than other than
focusing on what's happening now that is
such an unbelievably unacceptable answer
are you going to completely
de-legitimize the third branch of
government by making it an overtly
political institution
in which you just stack the court with a
bunch of democrats
and he says well you'll find out after
the election you'll find out
you know afterward we have to pass the
bill to find out what's in it as nancy
pelosi once said
about obamacare we found out what was in
it one that great
you have to elect me to find out what
i'm going to do is a crappy
unbelievably crappy response to are you
going to completely wreck
the third branch of government that's
wild that is wild stuff and the media
just sit there and they accept it
i mean they really accept it seriously
there's an article
in the washington post today talking
about how republicans pounce
very very pouncy see here's the rule in
the media as my friend andrew clavin has
said when republicans do something bad
that
the bad thing is the story when
democrats do something bad
the republicans pouncing is the story
the washington post headline was
republicans continue attacking biden
harris over hypothetical
court-packing question hypothetical
is that hypothetical when your your own
people have put it out there
when you have said that you refuse to
like hypothetical imagine if somebody
asked donald trump
are you for a federal ban on all
abortions from point of conception
and he said you know we'll have to we'll
have to find out after the election
where i stand on that particular issue
like maybe maybe not i don't know you're
gonna have to find out like you think
the media would be satisfied with that
answer but now
it's republicans pouncing of course so
much pouncing
it's a hypothetical pouncing according
to the washington post democratic
nominee joe biden and running mate
kamala harris are facing growing
pressure to say whether they would pack
the supreme court if the republican-led
senate names amy coney barrett to the
bench
over the past few days the question from
republicans debate moderators and
reporters has dogged the pair
it came up again thursday when biden was
asked at a campaign stop in phoenix if
you would support expanding the supreme
court beyond nine justices it
re-answered the conversation in earnest
after the death of rbg
although the republican control tenant
refused to consider barack obama's
nomination in merit garland in 2016
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
and his allies have promised to confirm
barrett by november 3rd yes because
the republicans control the executive
and the legislature
or at least the senate in response some
democrats have vowed to leave nothing on
the proverbial table should the party
take control
of the white house and the senate senate
minority leader chuck schumer hinted he
would not rule out
court packing again it is amazing that
the washington post is covering this as
a story of republicans pouncing
if you were talking about the
republicans adding seats to the supreme
court which they could theoretically do
right now they have a majority in the
in the senate presumably the democrats
and
the media would not be talking about
democrats pouncing they'd be talking
about the underlying issue
but joe biden is so confident that the
media will cover his ass for him
that he refuses to answer the most basic
questions knowing that he can literally
get away with anything they can ask him
any question under the sun
and he will say the focus right now the
focus right now should be on um
it should be on donald trump's
commission and the media will go you
know what he's right he's right that
trump guy he's bad
he's bad we don't need any answer
questions answered like
really we got nothing joe you're right
let's go ask some questions of
donald trump hey meanwhile joe biden
prepping the way for kamala harris to
become president so if you like what you
saw in that debate
meaning if you're adult then joe biden
has got somebody for you
he says that kamala harris was really
presidential now the fact that he feels
the need to say this
demonstrates where everybody's head is
at and i don't remember
donald trump saying this about mike
pence i remember george w bush saying
this about dick cheney well he's very
very presidential
what i remember more was he did a good
job in the debate see the president is
supposed to be presidential and the vice
president is supposed to be vice
presidential but because everybody's
afraid that biden's gonna plots on the
job
now biden is forced to talk about how
presidential kamala harris is when she
is
at the very least very non-presidential
smirky mcsmirk face
by the way love how the media treats
smirking if you're a high school student
and a native american activist comes up
to your face and bangs a drum in your
face
and you have an awkward smile that is a
smirk it's a smirk it's a racist smirk
if you're kamal harris and you smirk for
90 minutes against the vice president of
the united states while he simply
lays facts on you then that means that
you are slaying queen
anyway here was joe biden talking about
how presidential kamala harris was
i uh i thought commonly did a great job
last night
she was really presidential she kept it
on focus i was really proud of her i'm
looking forward to seeing it
well good news she'll never have to
answer a question as she didn't in the
debate
speaking of people who will never have
to answer questions nancy pelosi
laid out there yesterday that she wants
to create
a new commission that would be able to
objectively evaluate the president's
health
and mental health and deprive him of the
presidency and hand it over to the vice
presidency
so number one real backhanded slam slap
at joe right there and then nancy i mean
if you're so confident joe biden is
gonna be elected president
it seems like kind of a slap like you
think that joe's lost his mind and you
might have to hand it over to kamala
harris but obviously this is directed at
trump
and the belief that the 25th amendment
should not be left to trump's cabinet
instead
it should be left to some non-partisan
body which is to say people appointed by
people by like nancy pelosi here is
pelosi talking about
changing the 25th amendment to the
constitution to allow an outside body to
evaluate whether the president of the
united states ought to continue in his
job which is just insane
when we hear people saying i'm i'm young
and i'm a
perfect perfect specimen instead of
addressing the fact
that what 50 000 people were
in fact it reported to me in fact that
yesterday nearly a thousand people
died what are we talking about here
tomorrow
by the way tomorrow come here tomorrow
we're going to be talking about the 25th
amendment so what exactly is
she talking about well right now the
25th amendment allows for the temporary
ouster of a disabled president it
requires the active participation
of a majority of the cabinet pelosi
however is now saying that she wants
some other body to determine
whether in fact the president of the
united states ought to
ought to be ousted from his job pelosi
and representative jamie raskin
of maryland said in a press release that
they will introduce a bill creating a
commission to evaluate the presidential
mental and physical fitness
the bill would change to establish a
commission on presidential capacity to
discharge the powers
and duties of office that would enable
congress to help ensure effective and
uninterrupted leadership
in the highest office in the executive
branch of government so in other words
they're no longer
going to have to in any way impeach now
they will just go to the
commission on presidential capacity to
discharge the powers and duties of
office
and they will evaluate whether the
president of the united states is uh is
actually
worthy of continuing in his job by the
way that adult
octogenarian she's she's totally fine
we're told that donald trump has lost
his mind
but joe biden who will not answer a
single question and can't get through
seven sentences without
nearly falling off his feet and nancy
pelosi who's now said a coherent thing
in at least two years
these are the people who should decide
whether donald trump gets to stay in his
job after a
duly elected president becomes the
president
these are these are institutional
attacks on on the republican government
and i don't mean big-art republican i
mean small are republican these are
institutional attacks
but the good news is the media hates
trump so much that they will just ignore
all of them
in a second we're going to get to more
scandal dogging the biden campaign that
the media simply
will never ask joe biden about we'll get
to that in just one second first
let's talk about hair loss so here's the
reality a huge percentage of dudes two
out of three dudes will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they are 35 and you got to keep
the hair that you have because it is
very difficult to regrow hair
in my family male pattern involved in
this runs on both sides of my family and
that is why i
rely on keeps you used to have to go to
the doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit a doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered
right to your home they make it easy
they deliver your medication every three
months
so you can say goodbye to pharmacy
checkout lines and awkward doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there
you may have tried them before probably
never for this price again prevention is
key because
once you start seeing the hair fall out
a little too late
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months to see results it's
important to act fast the sooner you
start using keeps
the more hair you will save find out why
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors and more than one
hundred thousand men trust keeps for
their hair loss
prevention medication if you are ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
over to keeps.com receive your first
month of treatment for free that is
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash ben keeps.com ben to keep
the hair that you have okay meanwhile
stories that are just not going to be
covered
in the media other than you know a quick
blurb it turns out that devon
archer you haven't heard of devon archer
he was the business partner of hunter
biden
now turns out he's going to jail so
imagine that
the business partner of donald trump jr
we're going to jail
today and let's assume donald trump jr
had been jet-setting around the globe
picking up bags of cash on behalf of his
while using the name of his present and
father wouldn't that be like a big
scandal
wouldn't it be but apparently hunter
biden is a complete non-story
and the fact that hunter biden's
business partner is now headed off to
jail for fraud
that of course is a non-story as well
the wall street journal reports today
a federal appeals court reinstated the
conviction of a former business
associate of hunter biden
on securities fraud and conspiracy
charges ruling a lower court judge aired
last year in vacating a jury's verdict
a three-judge panel of the u.s court of
appeals for the second circuit ruled
that devon archer quote
knew at least the general nature and
extent of the scheme and intended to
bring about its success
the fraud involved the sale of 60
million dollars in bonds issued by an
economic development corporation
affiliated with the native american
tribe the proceeds were misused by
archer and others according to
prosecutors
archer and biden were business partners
at various times they served together on
the board of ukrainian gas producer
barisma holdings
hunter biden's name was invoked at
various stages of the fraud as a selling
point in transactions according to trial
testimony
but the son of the democratic
presidential nominee joe biden didn't
know about it was not involved with that
particular scheme according to hunter
biden's attorneys
federal prosecutors never alleged that
hunter biden was aware of the scheme
however he was deeply involved with
devon archer in a variety of businesses
where they were traveling around the
globe
picking up bags of cash in foreign
countries
this of course will never be asked
according to according to joe biden
hunter is pure as the driven snow so
that will never be asked meanwhile
donald trump may never get the chance to
ask some of these questions about court
packing or about anything else
because of course the commission on
presidential debate announced
unilaterally without consulting medical
authorities that they were simply going
to
cancel the second presidential debate
essentially they're going to make it a
zoom debate
well normally in order to do that they
said for health reasons wouldn't you
have to consult some doctors in order to
do that
apparently they didn't even bother to do
so it turns out that today
the the doctor for the president sean
conley released a health update on trump
said today the president has completed
his course of therapy for covet 19 as
prescribed by his team of physicians
this afternoon's vital signs were heart
rate 69 beats a minute blood pressure
127 over 81 which is quite healthy
respiratory rate 15 to 17 breaths a
minute and pulse oximetry
96 to 98 room air since returning home
his physical exam has remained stable
and devoid of any indications to suggest
progression of illness
overall he's responded extremely well to
treatment without evidence on
examination of adverse therapeutic
effects
saturday will be day 10 since thursday's
diagnosis based on the trajectory of
advanced diagnosis the team has been
conducting
i fully anticipate the president's safe
return to public engagements at that
time so in other words trump can do
public events according to his own
doctors by saturday
doesn't matter the the commission on
presidential debate decided it was going
to be a zoom debate
for no apparent reason like really
apparently there is no actual health
reason
why they had to do this and no and good
news the media of course
go right along with this which is not a
shock at all abc news has announced a
town hall
for joe biden moderated by george
stephanopoulos the partisan hack
keebler elf george stephanopoulos who
has spent the last
several weeks simply playing offense on
behalf of the biden campaign a guy who
two nights ago suggested
that that mike pence was mansplaining
to kamala harris now he's going to
moderate a town hall another propaganda
feat for joe biden on abc news october
15th
the primetime event will take place in
philadelphia where the former vp will
answer questions
from voters so i do love the fact that
um
apparently biden is going to fly in he
will be at the live event
with george stephanopoulos i don't think
he's gonna be there virtually
that's okay but if there's a debate
that's not okay
speaking of bias in this entire process
there's another presidential debate
moderator who has fallen under scrutiny
his name is steve scully he once
interned for joe biden apparently
which is like come on like this this is
just absurd they should get rid of the
commission on presidential debates it's
a joke
steve scully raised eyebrows thursday
night with a tweet that is
causing critics to question his
objectivity according to fox news
scully is best known as political editor
of c-span and host of washington journal
he apparently meant a direct message for
anthony scaramucci
he tweeted out scaramucci should i
respond to trump
that message was of course directed at
anthony scaramucci
scully was set to moderate a town hall
debate on october 15th
and that sparked confusion and fury
among critics odd thing for the next
debate moderator to tweet political
reporter alex thompson reacted
i mean that should be pretty
disqualifying you literally have a
debate moderator who's asking one of
trump's most vocal critics
how he should deal with trump openly on
twitter
wild stuff this all of this debate
moderation nonsense needs to stop as i
said yesterday the best form of debate
honestly would just be to have like
rachel maddow and me ask questions
at least you know you're gonna get harsh
questions from both sides of the aisle
at this point
meanwhile did joe biden answer any
questions on what he thinks the debate
should look like of course not
joe biden has never answered a question
he need not answer a question here was
joe biden
asking about the debate and being asked
about the debate and saying it's
irresponsible for him to comment
literally his entire campaign is here i
am in a mask and glasses
that's his entire campaign here i am i'm
an alive human
now i've said for a long time being a
live human might be enough
but it says something about our
political media that that's all they
demand of joe biden so they asked him
about you know how the debate should
take place
and instead of him saying follow the
science as he normally does right listen
to the doctors as he normally does
now he's like well i have no answers for
you you know carry on your day
here's joe biden don't know what the
president's going to do
change the mind every second so for me
to comment on that now would be
irresponsible i think that if i'm going
to follow the commission
recommendation if he goes off and he's
going to have a rally out
of um i don't know what i'll do so he
says i love that i love that he says if
he goes out and he has a rally
then i don't know what i'll do which is
a an open suggestion that he knows that
trump is healthy
he still won't have the debate amazing
there's talk about how biden was going
to try and avoid the debate
well now the commission on presidential
debate has just done the work for him
by putting forth his zoom debate
nonsense in just a second
we'll get to trump's response to all of
that first let us talk about the fact
that you need better employees hell i
need
better employees i mean let's suggest
that you want to start your show on time
it's very important day to start your
show on time
but your lead producer was too busy
going to the bathroom i mean here at the
daily wire we do not allow you
to go to the bathroom except in
accordance with national labor
relations act restrictions okay and
let's just be real about this producer
colton that's on your time man it's on
your time
let's say that you needed to replace
producer colton because he could not
control his that means
you need to head on over to ziprecruiter
zippercrew will send your job to over
100 of the web's leading job sites but
they don't stop there but they're
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and then actively invites them to apply
to your job ziprecruiter makes hiring
efficient and effective with features
like screening questions to filter
candidates and an all-in-one dashboard
where you can review and rate your
candidates
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day right now to try
ziprecruiter for free my listeners can
head on over to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-zip recruiter dot com
slash daily wired is the way to upgrade
your staff
even wonderful employees like colton who
apparently suffer
from some sort of uh some sort of
medical issue go check now
ziprecruiter.com
slash daily wire that got kind of harsh
on colton i feel like just a little
harsh anyway
anyway speaking of of harsh the
commission on presidential debate
pretty obviously bailing out joe biden
here
uh president trump said listen it's
pretty obvious here they're trying to
protect biden
i mean yes yes here
was trump yesterday they didn't even
tell us about the debate
so you just learned this this morning
yeah we learned it the same way you
learned it they called up uh
two minutes ago and uh it was announced
and they're
trying to protect biden everybody is
they're trying like that nbc disaster
where he went on
this show with lester holt it was like
it was meant for a child
okay that is a hundred percent true by
the way trump has had an alternative
suggestion
and biden hasn't taken him up on it so
trump's re-election campaign released a
statement
pointing out that trump will be
medically cleared for safe return by
saturday
he said there is therefore no medical
reason why the commission on
presidential debates should shift the
debate to a virtual setting
postpone it or otherwise alter it in any
way commission on presidential debate
chairman frank
ferenkopf admits they consulted with no
one before unilaterally changing the
format of the debate well in advance of
knowledge of what the president's
condition would be on debate night
the commission must stop protecting joe
biden from this in-person debate and
allow the event to proceed as it was
agreed to months ago
the american people can see through this
obvious attempt to shield biden from
another shellacking like he got two
weeks ago in cleveland
cpd must reverse course and let the
debate proceed that of course is correct
apparently trump is also proposing an
alternative which is okay let's hold the
second debate october 22nd it was
supposed to be
october 15th and october 22nd for second
and third debates he's saying instead
let's just delay everything by a week
you're so worried about it fine we'll do
the second debate the 22nd we'll do the
third debate october 29th
and biden's campaign's like yep that's
too close to the election you can't have
it both ways guys
you've been claiming that you can't
answer simple questions because voting
is already underway
so voting's already underway what do you
care how close to the actual election
date
any of this is that makes no difference
people have been early voting for months
according to you
okay meanwhile in in other news and this
again
goes to media bias it goes to the the
really bad faith
of democrats it's really amazing it's
really amazing so i have been
extremely consistent on my perspective
on the connection between political
rhetoric and violence
my perspective has been clear for
literally years okay here's the
perspective
if you are not openly advocating
violence if you're not advocating
violence you're not responsible for
violence
and if somebody misuses your words to go
do something evil
you are not responsible for them
misusing your words to go do evil also
you cannot impute
to somebody motive that they did not
actually
show meaning that if somebody goes and
does something and they have nothing to
do with
me or bernie sanders or donald trump or
barack obama
you cannot then claim that they have
something to do with us you cannot do
that
okay because that is unfair and it is
wrong there is
there is something called the scope of
agency in law there is a concept called
scope of agency
scope of agency is where i deploy an
agent to go do x right i want
i want producer colton to go to to go
pick up
something at fedex for the purposes of
the studio he is now my agent and going
to pick up the thing
at fedex for purposes of the studio okay
if colton
then for some odd reason decides to go
out and do cocaine on the side of the
road
that is outside the scope of agency i'm
not implying anything about colton's
activities
right now colton's really taken on the
shin today
the the fact is that outside the scope
of agency is outside the scope of agency
well
there is no agency when someone decides
to commit a terror attack against a
sitting governor
in the united states okay it's not like
donald trump was like you know what guys
i want you to go
perform a terrorist debt the reason that
i am bringing this up is because the
media and the democrats are now claiming
that donald trump is responsible
for an attempted kidnapping plot against
governor christine
governor gretchen whitman okay so
whitmer rather governor gretchen whitmer
according to the detroit free press
the wolverine watchman militia group
didn't just plot to kidnap governor
gretchen whitmer they're on a mission to
attack the state capitol
and target police officers at their
homes as part of a broader mission to
instigate a civil war according to
authorities
thursday they announced this in
announcing felony charges against 13
militia members accused in a sensational
case of domestic terrorism attorney
general dana nessel referred to the
accused as extremists who are hoping to
recruit new members by seizing on a
moment of civil unrest to wreak havoc on
the country
she identified the militia group as the
wolverine watchmen whose members are
accused of among other things conducting
surveillance outside whitmer's vacation
residents
using code language and encrypted
messages to throw off police and
planting a bomb under a bridge
to divert law enforcement so obviously
an
act of a tremendous evil they were
planning here nestle said there's been a
disturbing increase in anti-government
rhetoric
and the re-emergence of groups that
embrace extremist ideologies this is
more than just political disagreement or
passionate advocacy
some of this group's mission is simply
to create chaos and inflict harm
upon others okay so
the the implication the media have drawn
from this is that because these people
were anti-government
and wanted to start a civil war and were
members of
what would be probably termed a
far-right militia that they must have
been trump fans or that trump instructed
them to do all of this or something like
that
which is like republicans claiming that
the congressional baseball shooting is
the responsibility of bernie sanders
because a bernie sanders fan went and
shot members of congress
and nearly killed steve scalise but
here's the thing the right generally
refrains from this the left is not
the left tried to blame the oklahoma
city bombing on rush limbaugh now the
left is attempting to blame
this kidnapping plot on donald trump
the wolverine watchman group is one of
an estimated two to three dozen michigan
militia groups some fear could pose a
growing threat according to the detroit
free press
the state has always been a hotbed for
militia activities as amy cooter senior
lecturer
at vanderbilt university thursday law
enforcement arrested 13 people including
seven members of wolverine watchmen
apparently they wanted to kidnap her
take her to wisconsin and put her on
trial
for treason the conspirators were
frustrated and upset about many things
including the fact that during the
pandemic the state was controlling
gym openings they called whitmer a
tyrant b word and sought to train and
recruit others
into their ranks more than a dozen
people investigators had met in dublin
ohio and sought to form quote a society
that followed the u.s bill of rights and
where they could be self-sufficient they
discussed peaceful and violent ways to
do this well you know what is not in the
us bill of rights um actually kidnapping
sitting members of the government and
then attempting to execute them
it turns out these people uh can't read
apparently
they believe state governments were
violating the constitution and they
talked about murdering a tyrant or
taking a sitting
governor the wolverine watchman was
founded by pete musico 42 and joseph
morrison 26
who lived together in munich michigan
and are now each charged with a threat
of terrorism
throughout the summer the combined group
decided they needed firearms and
tactical training and homemade bombs to
blow up police vehicles and 200 men to
storm the capital
and take hostages they also discussed a
shooting at the governor's vacation
home and so most of by the way most of
the
militia groups in michigan according to
this professor
are law abiding so not all militia
groups are the same here's the
prosecutor
saying that their plan was a civil war
what they actually wanted was tremendous
levels of
violence in the streets
the individuals in custody are suspected
to have attempted to identify the home
addresses of law enforcement officers
in order to target them made threats of
violence
intended to instigate a civil war and
engaged in planning and training for an
operation
to attack the capitol building of
michigan and to kidnap
government officials including the
governor of michigan
okay so this prompted governor gretchen
whitmer
to say that this was all trump's fault
so this is an incredible thing
it really is it's like if republicans
had come out after the congressional
baseball shooting and overtly blame
bernie sanders
no one did this only members of the left
get away with this kind of crap
implying that their political opponents
are responsible for acts of violence of
which they not only do not approve
but in this case trump's doj was
intimately involved in the actual
prosecution here
but here is gretchen whitmer i mean it's
pretty it is pretty despicable
to claim that your political opponents
are responsible for acts of violence
against you
not the ones who are actually performing
the violence but people
broadly speaking who oppose your
lockdown policies but that's exactly
what gretchen whitmer does right here
just last week the president of the
united states stood before the american
people
and refused to condemn white
supremacists and hate groups
like these two michigan militia groups
when our leaders speak
their words matter they carry weight
when our leaders meet with encourage
or fraternize with domestic terrorists
they
legitimize their actions and they are
complicit
okay so i have a question then if we are
now going to use this logic presumably
the entire democratic leadership is
responsible for the excesses of black
lives matter who've been burning down
cities
again bernie sanders is responsible for
the congressional baseball shooting this
would make barack obama responsible for
the dallas police shootings that
happened back
in 2016. it would make barack obama
responsible for the riots that happened
in milwaukee
but we we can play this game all day
long we can play it
all day okay but this game is a stupid
game and it's an
immoral game and as a game apparently
democrats get away and the media just
backed them tim alberta of the
washington post
he tweeted out if the president read his
intel briefings and understood the dogma
of white nationalist groups he'd
realized that language like
liberate michigan is read as tacit
permission if not explicit encouragement
for militias to take action
okay you remember that back in the
middle of the pandemic
april 17th trump tweeted out in all
capital letters
liberate michigan and i at the time was
like
this seems like kind of a dumb tactic
like why don't you make a policy and
then tell people what your policy is
but you know liberate michigan is not a
call to do violence
against the michigan government amy
siskind
who is another member of the left-wing
media she tweeted out the fbi thwarted
what they described as a plot to
violently overthrow the government and
kidnap
michigan governor gretchen whitmer the
plot was hatched by michigan militia
recall the liberate michigan and
repeated rhetoric from trump
members of the media were not shy about
this keith boykin of cnn he said trump
called cnn the enemy of the people
caesar psych sends pipe bombs to cnn
trump tweets about anarchists and
agitators kyle rittenhouse kills two
people in kenosha
trump tweets liberate michigan six men
try to kidnap the governor
of michigan okay so number one if you
say that cnn is quote unquote the enemy
of the people
i've decried that language because
frankly i don't think that you should
use
the language of joseph stalin to
describe members of the media okay that
does not mean you are responsible for
people then threatening the media with
acts of violence
any more than the democrats have been
calling trump and they're calling him a
traitor and
a person who is giving incentive to
murder now if somebody goes and tries to
assassinate the president of the united
states on that basis i still don't think
keith boykins responsible for that
by the way linking kyle rittenhouse with
any of this is absurd kyle rittenhouse
did not go to kenosha to murder anybody
so even listing him there is just in
this list is just absurd on his face
liberate michigan is not is there any
evidence that we have seen
that it was that tweet that had anything
to do with anything like seriously
did at some point shouldn't you actually
require some evidence there's more
evidence that the congressional baseball
shooter was mimicking
the language of bernie sanders than
there is that these guys were following
trump's lead
especially because the alleged
ringleader declared donald trump an
enemy openly
he didn't like trump he thought trump
was a
right he wanted he he wanted civil war
he wanted unrest because he believed
that it was up to the militias to
liberate the country
here is the alleged ringleader literally
calling donald trump an enemy but we
ignore all of this of course because
the narrative has to be promulgated
trump is not your friend dude
and it's it amazes me that people
actually
like believe that when he's shown over
and over and over again
that he's a tiring every single person
that works for government
is your enemy okay so donald trump's the
president
calls him a tyrant used exactly the same
language that he used about
gretchen whitmer does not matter
according to the media this is all
trump's fault
this is how despicable the media are i
mean truly despicable and the fact that
gretchen whitmer gets away with that
that's a despicable thing to say it's a
despicable thing to say
it is gross at the highest level
i think that rashida talib and ilohan
omar are horrific cretins and
anti-semites i do not think they are
calling openly for violence against jews
in the united states
and i would not blame ilhan omar or
rashida talib if some terrorist
some islamist terrorist decided to kill
jews i would not blame rashida talib and
nohan omar
i can condemn their rhetoric without
suggesting that they are calling for
open violence against jews
okay you can do the same thing with
believe it or not you can make these
distinctions
nuances allowed in politics but here's
the point lack of nuance is the goal
it is not a bug in the system it is a
feature for democrats and for the media
they love
the lack of nuance and they love being
able to cast trump as some sort of
terrorist ringleader on on the basis of
nothing i mean it's just it's
gross okay we'll get to more of this in
just one second of course this is all
about creating a more
a broader overall narrative which is
again making the election referendum
on trump personally and making trump a
stand-in for supposed american racism
and if the if the square peg does not
fit into the round hole then you just
hammer away at the peg
until it fits into the hole we're gonna
see this in just a second america is
racist
america's evil and it doesn't matter how
you have to get to that conclusion
and you have to how you get to the
conclusion that trump is the ringleader
of this racist evil america
you just keep hammering away you just
keep hammering away and the media are
doing it
our business leaders are doing it the
culture clash in this country is getting
to the point where it is
getting almost unbridgeable we'll talk
about more of this in just one second
first
as you may have noticed this is a really
important election year a really
important election year
we've got senate races okay the senate
races are going to decide whether the
democrats are able to add new states to
the senate
pack the supreme court you got a
presidential race in which president
trump
is running against joe biden and joe
biden refuses to answer simple questions
about how radical he is going to be and
the stuff he has already said in his
platform
is damned radical enough if you're a
conservative you need to get active the
number one question i get from folks
is how can i get more active what can i
do i'm telling you right now
you need to go to keepamericaamerica.com
right now voting has already started in
some states
it is about to start in others if you
live in ohio early in-person voting
began 28 days before the election in
arizona it is 27 days before the
election
so you need to go to
keepamericamerica.com right now
they will get you the most trusted
up-to-date voting information while
you're there please commit to take one
person to the polls just one or help
them complete a mail-in ballot the 2016
election was decided by thousands of
votes not millions this could be a very
close election again
every little bit helps you need to do
your part go to keepamericaamerica.com
right now make this the biggest get out
the vote effort in conservative history
that's keepamericaamerica.com go check
them out right now keep america
america.com okay in just a second we're
gonna get to the broader
overarching narrative democrats are
trying to draw every
data point will be skewed and twisted to
fit the narrative that trump is a racist
and a stand-in for racist america a
deeply divisive and disgusting message
we'll get to more of this in just a
second but first earlier this week i
told you guys about a conference taking
place at the end of october expert
ownership live it's a virtual two-day
event about leadership
through crisis the conference will be
hosted by david and jason benham more
commonly known
as the benham brothers i know the venom
brothers they are excellent
conservatives
they are people who actually remember
them from home and garden tv they had a
show there
and then it turns out they were
conservative christians and hgtv was
like well we can't deal with those
people and they stood on principle
i'm excited to tell you that both
brothers david and jason are gonna be
special guests appearing on all access
live tonight
get on there you can talk to them about
the current state of business how to
build a multi-million dollar company and
you can ask about their past experience
as minor league baseball players which
is kind of fun these guys are great a
lot of fun to hang out with so if you
aren't a member yet it is time to join
the ranks as an all-access member
use code benham right now to get 20 off
remember only all access members get to
join these all access live sessions
where a daily wire host hops on during
the week to chat with you on live stream
and in the comments
the all access membership also features
not one but you
leftist years tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so
use code venom right now get 20 off if
you're not already a member and
join the bed and brothers live you don't
want to miss another great episode of
the sunday special by the way coming up
this weekend
this weekend we're joined by daley
wire's very own god king jeremy boring
it has finally happened
jeremy and i will talk about how we
started working together what his sad
dull life was like before we started
working together how we launched the
daily wire
where we go from here head on over and
watch at dailywire.com listen on apple
podcast spotify
or wherever else you get your podcast
also
it is indeed that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
wire member
today it's pence's head fly on twitter
who is not prepared for the incoming
tearduct tsunami in the pick
the world's greatest beverage vessel is
sitting in a baking pan to help contain
the bountiful harvest of tears the
caption reads i don't know what happened
pence asked harris about packing the
cord and it just started overflowing
i got i gotta find a bucket be right
back hashtag leftist years tumblr
vp debate well perhaps cardi b can help
you find both a bucket and a mop yes the
leftist years were indeed flowing well
done
vice president pence thanks for the
shout out thanks for being a daily wire
member you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so there is a broader
overarching narrative that the
whitmer allegations tie into and that is
that america is a deeply racist place
filled with white supremacist racists
who are being emboldened by the
presidents of the united states and
democrats are fighting back against this
this horrific infrastructure in the
united states
and corporate america has joined in on
this ridiculous quest
the media are all in on all of this all
you have to do is just cast your reason
out to the side all you have to do is
just
become completely blind deaf and dumb to
the actual real world in order to
believe this kind of crap
so a few examples karen atiyah who's
just an awful columnist over at the
washington post
and she's a woman of color herself i
believe that she
was up for the the pulitzer prize at one
point but she is definitely a victimized
human
she writes on international affairs and
social issues she has a piece today
titled america hates to let black women
speak all about how mike pence kept man
interrupting
man dropping kamala harris
karen nancy says it's hard to break
glass ceilings while walking on a
tightrope but in a historic debate
appearance on wednesday that's exactly
what kamal harris
had to do that plexiglas had to be
installed for the showdown between
harris and vice president pence was a
visible reminder that the trump
administration has recklessly played
down a deadly virus the plexiglas was
also an onstage reminder of the barriers
that non-white women face
when vying for political power in this
country
is that what the plexiglas was was it
because um it's plexiglass
so it was a visible reminder was the
plexiglas very
very interesting stuff also i'm just
going to note by most counts
she actually talked more than he did
also
is it really true that america hates to
let black women speak
oprah winfrey is a very very rich black
woman
she's been a very very rich black woman
maybe the most powerful and influential
cultural voice in america over the past
30 years
because america hates black women
michelle obama is the most popular woman
in america by polling data
she happens to be a black woman does
america hate to let black women speak
the main reason that kamal harris was
selected as vice president is for her
race and her gender that's not me saying
that joe biden said it he said he wanted
a black woman
right so is it because america hates to
let black women speak
the amount of stupidity that you have to
fall prey to to believe this narrative
is truly astonishing but don't worry
it's not just our media
that push this nonsense it is also the
the business apparatus
because businesses everywhere have
decided that it is their job to go woke
that the woker they get the more money
they will make now i think they are
mistaken in this particular
assessment i think that the woker they
get the more people are going to tune
out and find alternative ways of doing
business but here is the latest
from corporate america which again is
risk-averse and all they do is listen to
the squeakiest wheel
that's all they do is listen to the
squeakiest wheel which is why eventually
the right wing is going to get kind of
squeaky as well
and then corporate america is going to
have to make a choice do you wish to
simply ignore all the squeaky wheels
which is what you should do in order to
provide your product and services to
people or
are you just going to appeal to some
squeaky wheels and ignore the other
squeaky wheels in which case you will
end up with two separate business lines
the reason i bring this up is because
yelp today announced the dumbest policy
i have ever seen
a major corporation announce this is the
stupidest policy i have ever heard
yelp is now going to allow
consumer alerts you will be alerted if
somebody
alleges that a business has engaged in
racism i'm not kidding
so some crazy person walks into the
local
mickey d's and then pretends that
somebody wrote a racist thing on their
receipt this has happened like a
thousand times now in the media
yelp will now report that on the page
and issue a consumer alert
that perhaps this business is the site
of racism based on an unsourced
unverified allegation by random user i
can't imagine
how people would misuse this i can't
imagine that people would attempt to
shake down businesses
by basically saying you know what you
could do you could you know give me like
a free coupon or i could just go
on yelp and i could allege that you guys
were mean to black people i can't
imagine that anybody would misuse this
kind of thing
according to yelp quote when we noticed
an unusual
spike on an activity on a business's
yelp page our team of moderators will
investigate and temporarily
save and temporarily disable content as
we place an alert on the businesses page
to warn users that some of these reviews
may not be based on first-hand
experiences
but here's what we will do when an
incident involving racism occurs
will default to a general public
attention alert to inform consumers if
someone associated with the business was
accused of
or the target of racist behavior will
only escalate to a business
accused of racist behavior alert when
there's resounding evidence of egregious
racist actions from a business owner or
employee
such as using overtly racist lures or
symbols this alert will always link to a
news article from a credible media
outlet so users can learn more oh so
they'll launder all this crap through
cnn
great so as soon as you have a credible
news outlet
namely a left-wing news outlet that
accuses mickey d's of racism then you'll
just link to it and then
you'll issue an alert a business accused
of racist behavior alert
if somebody is accused of racism however
there will just be a public attention
alert
so there you don't even need evidence a
public attention alert will i can't
imagine how this will be abused
cannot imagine it and you're seeing this
kind of crap
emerge at corporations around the
country you already saw uber earlier
this year suggest that they were going
to give special discounts to black owned
businesses which by the way i believe is
federally illegal
i don't think that you actually are
allowed to discriminate on the basis of
race and pricing
it's an amazing amazing thing but
according to yelp communities have
always turned to yelp in reaction to
current events at the local level
as the nation reckons with issues of
systemic racism we've seen in the last
few months there is a clear need to warn
consumers about businesses associated
with egregious
racially charged actions to help people
make more informed spending decisions
oh is there is there now yes
no way this is misused probably it'll be
great
probably it'll be great okay meanwhile
how endemic is systemic racism i mean
when i talk about the media and the
corporate complex
pushing this notion that america's
systemically racist and that if you
don't say that america's systemically
racist you yourself are racist
i mean it okay there's an article today
from the washington post that is so
absurd on its face
that it ought to be completely
disregarded it will not be it is part of
a
six article series from the washington
post
titled born with two strikes how
systemic racism
shaped george floyd's life and hobbled
his ambition
okay now let's be real about george
floyd
whatever happened to george floyd and it
looks to me like excessive use of a
police force
to sit on the guy's neck for eight
minutes and 40 seconds
okay but that's excessive use of force
the case for murder is a lot shoddier
in fact even the case for excessive
force may not be shotty depending on
whether he was suffering from excited
delirium
okay whatever the case is with george
floyd george floyd
was not some wonderful person
who was who was bound for
glory in american life but then was
thwarted by systemic racism in america
that is not what happened to george
floyd
what happened to george floyd can be a
tragedy it could also be a crime but
that does not mean that america is
responsible for his personal failures
throughout the course of his life
the washington post tries to claim that
george floyd was bound for the supreme
court i kid you not
i'm not kidding you here are the first
words george floyd
did time in jail for pointing a gun at a
pregnant woman's stomach
by the way the woman i believe was of
color he pointed a gun at her stomach
during an armed robbery but according to
the washington post
that's just because of systemic american
racism i
i'm dead serious this is the idiotic
narrative you ready
his life began as the last embers of the
civil rights movement were flickering
out
it's horrific videotaped and ignited the
largest anti-racism movement since with
demonstrators the world over marching
for racial justice in his name
during the 46 years in between george
perry floyd came of age as the
strictures of jim crow discrimination in
america
gave way to an insidious form of
systemic racism one that continually
undercut his ambitions
early in life he wanted to be a supreme
court justice then a pro athlete
at the end he just longed for a little
stability training to be a commercial
truck driver
all were bigger dreams than he was able
to achieve in his version of america
weird because clarence thomas grew up in
the uh home of sharecroppers and ended
up on the supreme court conolisa rice
went to a church that was firebombed by
racist
it turns out that oprah winfrey grew up
in tremendous she was a single mom in
tremendous poverty
she ended up kind of successful michelle
obama has been pretty successful barack
obama's been pretty
successful but george floyd was hobbled
by systemic he was going to be a supreme
court justice was george floyd
it just ended up by coincidence that he
was in and out of jail for nearly all of
his adult life
and that he ended up with dying with
more fentanyl in his system than a horse
could handle
i mean like this is the most absurd
contention
it's absurd while floyd's lifespan
coincided with many advancements for
black americans says the washington post
some of them dramatic
his personal path highlights just how
much these hard-fought gains remain out
of reach for millions
like him my mom she always used to tell
us growing up in america you already
have two strikes
as a black man floyd's younger brother
felony said in an interview
you're gonna have to work three times as
hard as anybody else if you want to make
it
in the world like many black americans
floyd was behind long before he was born
and the whole thing
is about how george floyd was a victim
throughout his life
now again let's be real about this the
end of his life
can be a tragedy and also his entire
life can be a series of bad decisions
okay his his entire adult life appears
to be a series of
bad decisions and yet again this is the
fault of white america
it's the fault of white america amazing
amazing amazing
stuff but this is the narrative that the
media are attempting to draw
the the narrative that's being drawn by
people up to including michelle obama is
that america is racist and terrible
and that people who are protesting are
not in fact rioters and looters they're
just wonderful peaceful protesters and
we have to ignore the rioting and the
looting because of the greater point
which is that america is so systemically
racist that michelle obama is probably
the best-selling author
of the last 15 years in the united
states a front-runner for the
presidential nomination for the
democrats
if joe biden does not win or even if joe
biden leaves office at some point
it's it's hard to be it's it's so
terrible to be a black person in america
that literally the most admired people
in america are nearly
universally black at this point and
barack obama is black michelle obama is
black lebron james is black
look at a field in the united states and
you will see black faces in positions of
power which is a great
thing it speaks to the tolerance of
america the diversity of america
it speaks to the fact that we have an
open meritocracy that is an excellent
excellent thing but according to
michelle obama and the democrats again
america is systemically racist
and systemically evil so racist and evil
that people like george floyd according
to the washington post
are victims of systemic american racism
again the washington post printed an
actual article claiming that george
floyd's life
was a series of misadventures because of
systemic american racism
not because he was a repeat criminal who
was in and out of jail nearly his entire
adult life so here was michelle obama
just a couple of days ago
down playing rioting and looting
pretending that they don't exist in in a
video where she was calling trump and
america
by extension completely racist they're
stoking fears about black and brown
americans
lying about how minorities will destroy
the suburbs
whipping up violence and intimidation
and they're pinning it all on what's
been an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement for
racial solidarity
it's true research backs it up only a
tiny fraction
of demonstrations have had any violence
at all
only a tiny fraction hundreds have had
violence hundreds have had violence
a tiny fraction the study that she's
talking about suggested that only about
seven percent
of the protests across the united states
devolved into actual violence
oh well you know well if only seven
percent of tea party protests had
developed into actual violence probably
that would be mostly peaceful
as well completely ignoring rioting and
looting to
say that trump is a racist for pointing
out the rioting and looting he speaks a
particular vision of the united states
that is quite ugly and is quite wrong
hey it is a vision of the united states
shared by people like colin kaepernick
who's been treated as a hero
like an actual hero for being an
extremely wealthy
as it turns out mediocre nfl quarterback
he had one good season and then he
sucked so much that he was bench for
blame gabber
and that guy knelt for the national
anthem on the basis by the way of a
shooting
that happened i believe in oakland that
turns out was justified by the police
he wore a he wore a pair of socks
suggesting that cops were pigs this guy
is hailed as a hero
now he is saying not only that america
is deeply racist of course in every
respect
also he this this new goodwill
ambassador from the nfl
he has suggested that he is uh
that the police ought to be completely
defunded he published an essay
on tuesday with a message describing a
change of heart he's experienced
since holding his kneeling positions in
2017. he says he is now opposed to
reforming law enforcement at all
he prefers a total abolition of police
and prisons don't worry he's not a
radical guys
he's not a radical he just wants
mainstream police reform
he's just worried about excessive police
use of force he's not a radical in any
way
helen kaepernick he's the heart and soul
of racial justice reform
in the united states under the
sub-headline
sub-heading title f reform kaepernick
wrote his thinking was quote fastened
to a reformist framework he admitted he
missed the larger picture
or even major changes to policing would
produce similar problems to those that
in kaepernick's mind currently plague
law enforcement according to emily
zenati for daily wire
the focus on individual punishment will
never alter the outcome of a system
rooted in black death said kaepernick i
wanted change i wanted it to stop i
wanted to reform what i saw yet the
reforms often proposed use of force
policies body cameras more training
police accountability where the same
recycled police reforms consistently
proposed in the past
and in both the past and the present
these reforms have done nothing to stop
the actions that force us to say
their names so what does he want he
wants the end of policing and the end of
prisons
which is crazy you need police to
enforce
the law colin kaepernick needs the
police to protect presumably his
multi-million dollar estate and his very
expensive cars that he is
that he has achieved in this
horrifically racist and backward country
he says despite the steady cascade of
anti-black violence across this country
i'm hopeful we can build a future that
imagines justice differently
a future without the terror of policing
in prisons terror of policing
it seems like terror of criminals would
be a more justified terror
a future that prioritizes harm reduction
redemption and public well-being in
order to create a more just and humane
world
oh isn't that nice of course this
doesn't involve any solutions as you may
have noticed
he says the ever-present threat of
premature death at the hands knees
choke holds tasers and guns of law
enforcement has only further ingrained
its anti-black foundation into the
institutions of policing
in order to eradicate anti-blackness we
must also abolish the police the
abolition of one without the other
is impossible he says that this will
have wide-ranging effects but he resists
the urge to explain how ending law
enforcement will result in an end to
homelessness and other social ills
other than to speculate that money spent
on policing will be redistributed
in a way not guided by white supremacy
of course white supremacy
he says by abolishing policing in
prisons not only can we eliminate white
supremacist establishments we can create
space for budgets to be reinvested
directly into communities to address
mental health needs homelessness and
houselessness
access to education and job creation as
well as community-based methods of
accountability ah yes if we just dump
trillions of dollars
into local government initiatives
focused on like you know say like head
start programs or midnight basketball
probably that will solve the crime
problems except that the only thing that
ever solved the crime problem in the
united states is more cops on the street
end of story that's the end of it okay
the
if there is one robust finding in social
science it is that more cops on the
streets
means less crime but of course
kaepernick doesn't care about that
because he doesn't have to deal with the
consequences of crime he's got the
entire media massaging his shoulders
as he declares the entire police
establishment racist and he's got the
democratic party mimicking this language
it is pretty amazing stuff that
kaepernick again he's supposed to be a
moderate he continues to say the same
things that michelle obama says
they keep saying things like the threat
of death from law enforcement against
black americans is ever present
it is hard to think of a graver lie than
this that is such an
unbelievable lie statistically speaking
it is not ever present
statistically speaking there are 42
million black americans
in the last several years the number of
black unarmed americans
killed by the police has been under 20
out of 42 million people but apparently
the threat of death
is is ever present no matter what you
are doing okay this is again an attempt
to draw a narrative about america that
is just a lie
it is just a lie and that lie has
consequences because as it turns out
those who want to defund the police are
jacking up the rate of homicide and
violence
i love this the washington post finally
noticing this quote the homicide rate is
spiking
a troubled police department is reeling
from street demonstrations seeking
racial justice and accountability and a
city budget is ravaged by the
coronavirus economy this in oakland
the push to reshape police departments
is occurring in cities across the
country but it is perhaps nowhere more
evident than here in oakland where
veteran activists want to sharply reduce
the police budget
but much of the broader community is
struggling with what that could mean
in a place that for the past decade has
been dedicated to rethinking how it
polices its people
the argument for a smaller force and
larger social service agencies has
gained momentum
the nearly immediate calls for cuts of
up to half of the police department's
300 million
budget were popular among protesters but
cutting a municipal police force in a
large city
has proved highly complex at a time when
the economic slowdown caused by the
pandemic
has greatly reduced the amount of public
money to go around and crime has spiked
oakland has seen a surge in shootings
and homicides which in the second
quarter of this year had more than
doubled from the previous one violence
and vandalism that have come with some
of the street protests have rattled the
business community that supports in
principle
a more preventive approach to addressing
crime one of the beautiful things about
being a democrat
about being a member of corporate
america that backs this kind of
anti-racist
garbage and i put anti-racist in scare
quotes because that's the ibram candy
robin deangelo version of anti-racism
which has nothing to do with racism and
everything to do with neo-marxist
claptrap
the predictable results of this are more
minorities getting hurt
more people dying more businesses being
looted more businesses being broken into
but colin kaepernick doesn't have to
care and michelle obama doesn't have to
care they don't have to care they know
full well
the consequences of what they say but
since they are being back massaged by
a democratic establishment that is
perfectly willing
to and not just willing eager to forward
the narrative of a racist america
these are the heroes these are the
heroes in america the people who are
making life worse every day
for people desperately in need and more
of more law enforcement
not less law enforcement people
desperately in need of more opportunity
not less opportunity and people
desperately in need of more
encouragement in a free society
not the pervasively disgusting message
that you are born
with two strikes on you no matter what
in the united states if you are born
black which is just a lie
alrighty we'll be back here today with
two additional hours of content
otherwise we will see you here
on monday try not to wreck things this
weekend i know i say this every single
weekend
i would love to come off the the last of
the jewish holidays i'd love to come off
the last of the jewish holidays
on sunday night and for things not to be
on fire so see if you could do me that
little favor
if not whatever i'll be here to recap it
with you on monday i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen